Chẳng Người ai ngay căn thẳng dự í văn và yên lòng thang Trung Quốc duy trì kết tâm cận thật chào không đứng hành về phía hảo.
Chú tích tập cận bình bản tò quán gại sâu sắc và kêu gọi các bên kính chế, đồng thời căn kết,
bắt kinh sẽ đón phái chào sây dân trong nỗ lực khói phục ổn địa khu vực.
Mọi trường vương nghỉ đã liên tục chơi đổi với dời chức iram Israine và Oman để thuộc đẩy giải phát hoại sâu.
Tuy lên tiếng phản đối hình đồng quốc dự quay saran, Trung Quốc vẫn tìm cách giữa kinh đối thoại với cả hai phía.
Bắt kinh cũng hỏi yên một đăng phái chào chung xanh hoại sài trong cuộc khủng hạn.
Rồi truyên xanh nhận định đấy là một chính xanh hoại sáo liên hoạc,
bơ dưới chiếc thế cân bằng vừa tìm kiếm cơ hội cùng có vị thế.
Theo các nhà phần tách Trung Quốc không muốn xung đột anh hưởng tới lỗi xanh hạn tại khu vực.
Và thành viên của SEO và BRICS iram của ý nghĩa được về bắt kinh nhưng điều đó không đồng nghĩa về một sự cảm kết bố được kia.
chính xác của Trung Quốc phản nánh giáo xù vương đặc lợi của ra làm Trung tâm cho bối cảnh cảnh trang địa chính trị này cảnh cây gắt.